pendant tout ça alors etienne t'arrêter
fumée ça fait une semaine pour crier
victoire
suite
moi j'arrête qu'elle était à terre c'est
très bizarre ça change tout ça change
tout comportement j'étais habitué à
avoir jeté enfin j'étais un gros fumeur
c'est surtout quand on se retrouve dans
des endroits comme vous comme ici pas
mal bu un peu la sympathie
ces deux voies vers le territoire vas tu
arrêter de chanter parce qu'on comprend
pas quand tu chantes sur celle par
exemple nom dans le journal c'est pas
moi je te diront ceux qui viennent en
général ils connaissent les chansons par
coeur ce n'est pas très grave
un des reproches de tourner mais on
comprend pas très bien et chante il n'y
a pensé passer à nouveau empêché la
vente de 400 mille fois toute façon y
aller les paroles sur les pochettes
oui c'est pour ça et start façon
maintenant ça change plus rien
maintenant qu'elle sida c'est terrible
je veux dire non pour les stars pire
qu'avant compléter ce tour mais plein de
succès avec les ppp maintenant moi je
trouve le plus souvent connu que
maintenant c'est plus facile que pour
voir c'était plus facile
parce que des magouilles ça marchait
bien c'est pas que ça c'est pas que ça
donne ça marchait mieux il ya toujours
un attrait de la part des gens parce que
tu ai connu un qui peuvent ne s'est pas
tu dragues et où quelque chose qu'à 7 à
écouter toujours vraiment solliciter
tout c'est plus ce que c'était plus
facile avant puisque maintenant je sais
pas du tout si c'est moi d'un
terrassement barrière
mais bon je les repère a les deux
http nightclubbing non plus un crocodile
fait acheter la descente buffalo bills
thérapeute toile c'est vrai que 14 qui
sont aujourd'hui dans les cages de sens
bien donc je leur dis que les gens
avouent est en effet d'abord tu et à toi
et puis tout le night clubbing s'est pas
suffisamment excitant pourquoi
donc on y passe est né ou alors
peut-être j'ai vieilli mais je sais pas
ce que tu consommes musicales et des
zags c'est pas une période en s'amusant
et robert de la pose de
je me sens beaucoup mieux en france là
j'ai refait j'étais ravie par rupture de
stock comme on voudrait nous faucher les
arènes et c'est quand même bien chaud
ouais je vois évoluer comme ans après le
trip parce que la cepam l'adolescence
prolongée qui n'en finit plus tu vois
doivent non moi j'ai pas l'impression
aux faits reprochés cinq ans maintenant
oui de cette chanson qui s'appelle le
where is my booky parce que tu as perdu
ton petit singe à 30 ans on trouvait
beaucoup de gens que ce mouvement cette
chanson ça ça parle où toutes les
frustrations condamne
parano chaque fois de plus
tout ce qui est désagréable brésil mais
c'est vital c'est une idée marrante
pourtant passé un truc peut-être un peu
plus
vous avez une fois j'ai l'impression
d'avant le même âge depuis onze ans
c'est fini ça tu as grandi
donc je ressens de réagir de la même
façon devant
d'avoir le même type de comportement et
réaction pour avoir chaud sûrement pas
bougé moi je voulais parler du
questionnaire de proust
quel est pour toi le compte de la misère
le compte de la misère c'est lorsqu'il
ya pas de bière dans l'es7 avant d'aller
dans l'idéal de bonheur terrestre
on y donne du bonheur terrestre en fait
c'est enfin je vis un exposé idéal de
buzz internet ans et rajeuni
une passion je mettrais bien mon passion
je ne sais pas mal auquel faute à tulle
plus maintenant j'étais à l'orthographe
c'est tellement et qu elle
et le mensonge pour ce faire l affaire
les qualités préférée celle à sa fille
c'est la table
le pas la vertu
bon sur une perte de temps la vertu est
trop vertueux
des battoirs non
c'est en occupation préférée une
occupation préférée
gala beaucoup
les petites choses agréables de la gym
les découvrir et
mais j'ai pas prendre un verre est
agréable c'est pas un gros studio mihail
je dis toujours que sa demande que tu te
casses en vacances traitement
je porte a vraiment
quand je suis arrivé à un stade où cents
ou quoi c'est presque heureusement oui
atteint leur passion comment tu aimerais
vous rires j'aimerais mourir
d'une façon romantique j'aimerais
de façon extrêmement tragique
un moment spectaculaire par exemple de
nôtre côté jamal
un soin d'eux
et propres l'état présente dans l'esprit
plutôt bien là plutôt bien j'apprends
justement par rapport à ce que j'ai dit
alors j'apprends à ne rien faire ce qui
est en grande première
la devise de vie